So now I need to log into Foundry again and then it's gonna be take me like an hour.
Yeah.
We just left all and join again.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
I can hear you again.
Let's go.
I was like, I was hearing everybody then all of a sudden everything just cut out and I was like, what the fuck?
Was it a bit?
Surprisingly.
Not surprisingly.
He spanked that ass.
Not fully agree but close.
Yeah, I forgot the temp.
Oh no.
I'm sorry.
Yes.
And using the curse to love stone he's going to roll with advantage.
Yes, magic.
That is beautiful.
That's beautiful.
My role is higher though.
Oh, okay.
All right then.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
I shouldn't have done that.
By the way, isn't stunning strike on a hit or it's just a normal pay.
You hear the entire thing.
Bob sees him attack with full force and pulls his shield in front of him casping shield.
Let me catch you real quick.
That brings up his AC for now.
Why is shield not applying?
Yes.
I'm sorry.
Did he come towards me?
Do I get any opportunity attack as he goes back?
I'm sorry.
Okay, where is beer?
Oh, quick on it.
Then quick on it again.
That will not hit either.
By the way, just to let you know I have a plus stand on this.
So the roles are horrible.
The guy in front of me.
Okay, 20 more hits.
I'm sorry.
How do you damage?
That is five damage and with Bob does as it strikes him.
Bob also.
Where is it?
As it strikes him, Bob also pops a little bit off.
Since after dying he has in his veins toxic blood going on around his body.
As it strikes him, he coughs up a bit of toxic fuel at him doing divine smite at first level.
And I have no idea where divine smite is.
Oh, there it is, divine smite.
You can do the damage, you roll damage, so that's a 15.
I'm sorry.
Obviously my last use of shield.
Now it's 26 now, there you see.
No, I cast it again.
I have a minus one to deck, those transitives.
Wait, it's a save or check.
Nope.
Well, the usual three poults from the spear.
No, it's grapple, I'm not restrained.
Let's go.
Okay, and with these two hits he does the damage and then he just wants to go all out.
So, the damage for this one, and it's a total of 15 piercing damage.
So, my advance might should be somewhere over here there.
Damage, roll damage.
I'm not that can advance my for 11, so yeah, 13, 16, 10, 32 and 10, 42 damage on this round.
And if I'm, yeah.
I'm not that can't do anything.
Okay, I actually rolled pretty high for advance, like, okay, that makes sense.
I promise a pool of noxious, like toxic blood all over like shackles face and shackle goes like shackles eyes, pop go back at all the few men, the talk the gas.
I need to go to sleep this.
Oh, this hurts so bad.
I'm not that can't do anything.
All looks at that.
We agreed on the rules before here.
I want to look at Bob.
I want to see more.
Okay, Bob looks at Baptiste and says, so is the plan that as long as I'm not going down, you're going to make me fight.
He's making it useful.
Yeah, Bob looks a little smile and then Baptiste, what's your AC by the way?
Let's see.
Just kidding.
I'm just asking if someone doesn't move when you're attacking them.
Do you need to do an attack rule?
No, I'm not talking about Baptiste.
If someone doesn't move when you're attacking them, do you need to do an attack rule?
Let me just do the damages.
Let me say it first.
For the first 17, I don't need to do the attack rule.
17 times 2 is what?
The damage is 20.
So 34 and 24 is 54.
I'm just asking if someone is going to attack me?
By the way, out of character, I actually have to leave early that's why I did that.
Let me move.
Time for roll.
I'm just asking if someone is going to attack me?
Remember, I got your baby.
Are you kidding me?
No, it's not 20.
Let's do this.
I'm waiting on Rift's introduction.
He'll be fine.
What the fuck? Why do you call that a tie?
I'm just asking if someone is going to attack me?
Oh, right.
How close is he?
He's with him 15, so we all...
We're going to do that little movement right there.
Take that man right there.
Get him the old double whack whack.
No.
I'm just asking if someone is going to attack me?
He's going to attack me?
Why do we do that?
Did he move back?
The first one was the...
He just is 27.
Fuck.
I'm just asking if someone is going to attack me?
I clicked it.
Oh fuck.
Yes, I do. You already know.
So I have a question.
Oh shit.
You fuck.
27.
Well, the healing was for nothing.
By the way, was the healing like an action or bonus action?
Oh wow. He healed 40 on bonus. God damn.
By the way, Roma has advantage on the sturdy safe.
Why?
Isn't fireball a dead sage?
Yeah, that's... why would I have a advantage?
No, he's a barbarian, right? They have like danger sense or something that gives them advantage on the dead sage.
Oh, I do have danger sense.
Yeah, fuck the fireball. Come on.
Oh, thanks again, Z.
18.
Jesus Christ.
30, Father.
All right, listen. Your little pukes stick.
I didn't want to fight you. You're the one your captain was the one who made us do this.
So now it's not only are you getting an ass whooping?
Okay, what's your little, what's your little sand body parts?
You asked for it.
What?
Oh, shit, my skillet went back to the other skillet on this one.
I'm not going to get fried yet.
It's a very original the names.
It won't let me.
I didn't give me any temp HP. I'm still at 35.
Okay.
I'm going to get some trouble.
I think. Yeah.
I'm going to do it again. I'm going to swing twice.
Hold on. Is that a bonus action?
It is a bonus action to go that side.
It's still swing twice.
You do have action search.
25.
And the next one.
Oh my god. That one's not hitting.
So, damage.
24.
So, be like, like I told you you asked for it.
Fucking wind up like I'm fucking in Babe Ruth and just crack him in the chest.
I'm going to do it again.
I'm going to turn to the monkey boy and be like, yo monkey boy.
Do I got to kill him?
Or you just don't give us the guy.
We went three and a half.
And the last guy.
Do we got to whoop your entire crew's ass?
You just going to give him to us.
Let me get you a know he doesn't.
I'm asking you what are we doing?
We just whoop three of your crews ass.
Go right.
There we go. Race it in.
We are the first crew.
I don't want to turn back.
I'm still selected targets.
That's why I am so sorry.
I'm not going to turn back.
Bob is over there groaning in his sleep.
It's a race.
Did we get a name?
I'm not going to turn back.
It's your bad.
What is this?
I'm not going to turn back.
I just looked at something and realized where this.
I just looked at something and realized where this is.
I think you didn't do it.
Well, now it was still the monkey's turn technically.
That was his dash.
I'm not going to turn back.
The attack did hit.
Get your hand off my dog.
I'm not going to turn back.
We know who's better.
I want to watch this.
I'm not going to turn back.
Did you roll the save?
I did that out.
Bob tries to do some low effort like claps and then goes, "Glaah!"
If luck perchance takes you there, that could help you train.
If you tell me, "Jagelses!"
Bob tries to do some low effort like claps and then goes, "Glaah!"
Bob tries to find him.
You're right. What's going on?
I told you guys I wanted this little guy to come with us right. I got him in the barrel.
So it's before we helped decide and it's good rate of insert pressure. Yeah I told you I want to take it with us.
You know how much fun he would be on the ship playing playing songs.
Like, the whole overhouse full of people who play instruments.
Why am I the one person who is actually changing this island?
Cuz bro you know how funny that would be.
That is not funny.
You like you like. Come on think about it.
And I was gonna have Bob right at the end. That's how he was going on tour.
And also he plays the electric guitar. You know awesome that is.
Roma you value revolution. See you nuts.
Now I have value responses.
We're starting to say I don't give a shit about revolutions.
I don't get I don't get shit about the end.
I want the action the fights.
The results.
I don't give a shit what happens afterwards.
Roma.
Let me take it. We can we can drop them off at the next island.
Let me take them with us. Come on.
Well, they get somebody. Do you know somebody else who plays guitar?
I just want them to play. Give a C-shanties. Give me something.
I know someone who can sing.
Who?
Well, she's kind of missing right now.
Talking mermaid.
It's number 20.
What are the twins? Who the fuck is the twins?
Oh, I broke a broken throat. Remember I shatter that thing.
She ain't ever going to talk again.
I don't want her I don't want her to come.
What is she going to be evil?
You said you just wanted someone to give you these shanties.
I said I want somebody who will play something nice like C-shanties.
How do you think if it's going to react to this?
Oh, I think he's going to be pissed, but I think he would also have fun.
I don't think.
You know, this may it doesn't want to actually be a ruler of the island.
Like he ain't got that personality in him.
He wants he wants to have adventures. He wants to have fun.
He doesn't want to be litigating a quarrel since.
Come on, boss. Look at how we fought.
He was leader of the Ristans.
You think he won't want to govern?
You think he's going to want to rule the island?
No, he wants to follow.
Why do you think he follows?
To get the love of his life.
He's the leader.
That's like saying, that's like saying Han.
Han wants to rule.
Han doesn't want to rule.
Lay is the one who wants to rule.
What the fuck are these guys?
I have no idea.
I'm just speaking language.
I spoke this shit and stuff.
No, but you know what I'm saying.
But you're not going to rule.
I'm going to wait for the love of his life.
No, I ain't. No, I ain't.
They always get barred.
He will be back.
He doesn't have to leave.
Hey, Ruma, you want to get her as well?
No, no, no.
Someone's got to stay behind the rule.
She's the ruler.
He just did it just for her, you know.
He just wanted to help.
And I know he's going to want to help other people out
there on scene.
He's going to want to trust me.
Because as bad as his island was, there's other islands just
as bad.
And he's going to want to help those people too.
I'm just saying.
And the love of his life can rule this island.
He'll be back for her.
She knows it.
We just got to take him for a little bit.
Tell we could get somebody else that plays--
or hear me out.
Somebody else that can learn how to play some.
Hey, about teased.
You know, drug can come back--
Dravis can come back with him, you know?
That's what I'm saying.
We just got to take him for a little bit.
No.
We don't--
God, damn it.
You're no fun.
[LAUGHS]
Rommel, we don't even know if we're
going to make it to another island before we had to--
our next destination.
Are you-- are you going to go with us
to the next destination?
Are we going to the fucking--
This is in the North blue.
We are in the blue.
And we got a man who could teleport.
It takes weeks for him to be able to do that.
He's all-- exactly.
He's all going to be done on a couple weeks.
That's a week.
People don't have-- they're in a rebuilding process.
Exactly.
They rebuild it.
They ain't got nothing to do for the next couple weeks.
They just rebuild it.
That's not how rebuilding works.
What you mean?
To rebuild.
They need leaders.
They got one.
His girl.
Did you not hear the S?
The one?
The road.
And also, secondly, we just go and leave the island
with the crazy bitch out wandering around.
We got away.
Where are you going?
The other twin that you mentioned.
They'll go find her.
Well, I'm just saying.
She-- I'm just saying we just take him with us.
He just-- I don't make a deal with you.
Yes, sir.
If you find her, I will consider you being able to take
risk.
[INAUDIBLE]
Roma, you ready?
Yes, sir.
What the fuck?
Just come back.
Exactly.
Yeah, believe this.
We actually find her.
This is going to be epic.
And also, I was like trusting Baptiste
to like persuade Roma because Barbarians say anything.
So Baptiste didn't say anything.
Oh, this is going to be fun.
I was hoping Baptiste was going to go along with it.
Just came over.
Why would I thought along with it?
Why would we?
Because I'd be fucking funny.
And Baptiste seems like he's in the funny.
I'm just saying it'd be awesome to take him with us.
Same.
If it was the old Bob, he would be like furious.
But now Roma has got an endless supply of guidance for this.
[LAUGHS]
You followed Roma.
Dude, this guy's chaotic neutral alignment now.
He's fucking high.
What do you think?
He's going for the phone.
Oh, God.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Malphist, you want to--
All right, Bob.
This is what we going to do.
We're going to go back more than we want.
We're going to go back to the hall.
She was bleeding.
We just got to try to follow the blood or pick up
a zit or some clues from where she went from there.
Malphist, you want to join?
We only have to--
No, no, no, no.
Wait a second.
Who was bleeding?
What?
That lady, the singer.
The lady we got to find.
Aren't we trying to find the first lady
that we met after a come-to's?
But--
That we're trying to find the twin.
Oh, we're trying to get the twin.
Oh, OK.
Yeah, same thing.
Yeah, I'm down.
Yeah, we just got to find her.
She's going to be someplace on this island still.
Hiding from us.
Bob is thinking, like, there is no way
we're going to find her.
Like, she's probably going underground,
but on the outside, he's going to like, hell yeah.
That's fine there.
But at the same time, hopefully--
here we are, hopefully, the people have grown strength
and found her and imprisoned her.
So then all we have to do is literally go find some clues,
see that they did that, and then she's
sitting in a jail cell someplace.
Because the people we are just
landing the whole-- we're spending the whole night
shallow cooms in this shit.
Exactly.
Because already made the meal.
The meal is done.
It's been cooked.
We're partying now.
So instead of us partying, we're
going to be out and show a lot of cooms in this shit.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
So--
Whoa.
Baptiste gave us the ultimate number.
I got to find that singer twin that got away.
And if I do, I could take a riff with us.
You know, that will cost a bit of it.
He's not here to let me take a riff.
No.
A bit of it.
No, no, that will cost a bit of it.
That's like a deal.
Yes.
Yep.
So--
And Bob is like putting on a coat like--
you know, like Dr. Watson.
Bob is like putting on a coat, coat like that.
So Bob gives Roma a beret, and I like his car,
or something like--
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
Oh, my--
Getting without a barrel.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
Can you--
Whoa.
Hey, there.
Can you take a riff back home?
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
What's going on?
That's what you're doing.
Yeah.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
You really--
Oh, no, that's--
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
Well, Roma tried to catch a hit in the view.
Yeah.
So he has this crazy idea that we're taking a riff at us.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
Not if he can help it.
He came back home.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
Before we leave, like as we are living,
how far is the ship from the city?
From where we are?
Ah.
Never mind.
Oh, never mind.
I thought I was going to call my mom for some extra help,
but never mind.
I'm looking for any signs, blood, anything that I can follow.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
I'm going to follow the one where she ran through.
Oh, no.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
Ah, we should have brought the wolf.
Yeah.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
Let's check.
Is there any blood on the ground, like droplets?
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
Are there any people around it?
And I--
Who needs to hold back?
I think we should ask around.
Oh, I don't know if we can--
Yeah.
I'm going to point the blood out to Bob and see if he can pick up a trail.
Yeah, like if I can see the blood, be like, hey,
do you see a trail or something forming from this?
Ah, hi.
After all that, I have lost a lot of my stuff,
but let me try this.
And Bob has detect magic.
Face measure template?
No.
And there it is.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
Hey, I got something.
Let's come on, come on, come on, come on, and Bob dashes.
And I'm going to be sitting there watering behind him.
[END PLAYBACK]
Wait, how many feet, drop?
Let me just check one thing real quick.
How high is Bob right now?
40 feet.
No, no, no, no, no, no.
He is smoking.
How high?
Well, I was in stones.
Yes, I can.
And I hope I fail.
Yes, nice.
OK, so Bob, like he has been with Roma with his all antics
up until now for since he is high.
And he, like, maybe after seeing the cliff from his tops
and Bob goes, come on, we've got to find her.
And he strays up jumps.
I'm going to grab him before you take the leap.
Hold on, I'm going to get it.
No, no.
Oh.
Yeah, I'm going to resist.
I'm going to do the resistance.
Oh, shit.
Yeah, never mind.
Oh, save.
Yeah, same thing.
Won't hear-- oh, shit.
OK, never mind.
Come on, we've got to get--
Yeah, we got to think about--
we got to get down there.
How do you want to get down there, Bob?
We ain't jumping because that's not water at the bottom.
We're not just jumping off the cliff.
If it was water, you couldn't jump anyway.
OK.
I thought you were going to have to go.
At this point, I'm just going to shove him off the cliff.
Thank you.
Yeah, I really hope you do that.
Yeah, Roma does that.
OK, there's no take back.
I've d6.
40 feet.
What would that--
Yeah, give all that 19 damage to me.
Come on, give it to me, Daddy.
I have a feeling it's going wrong.
He said give it to me, Daddy.
He's high now, OK?
He's kinky.
Yeah, 31.
Bob goes, "Come on, Roma, are you coming or what?"
Oh, shit, I got a roll.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Yeah, I still keep my--
Even after the like heading with getting ahead with the branches,
he still does like the goggles that he's using the detect magic for.
So the spell is still on.
He yells out, "Roma, are you coming or what?"
And then he dashes towards the trail.
Roma?
I'm going to eat those two little dessert things I got.
Oh, yeah.
Are we doing this?
Where the hell is it?
There are some nodes.
Definitely for probably.
The new effects are pretty awesome.
Oh, wow.
Am I seeing those?
So that's one is five.
Oh, we should--
This is so awesome.
Yep.
Five again.
All right, I'm jumping off, too.
I'm saying fuck it, he made it.
Oh, yeah.
But I'm going to be smart.
You said there's branches on the way down, right?
I'm going to try to--
Yeah, I'm going to try to catch like branches to slow myself down.
Do you want--
Stay less.
I'm going to try if it fails and fails.
I got lay on hands, don't worry.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Come on, Roman.
You see that?
That's like over there.
Come on, come on, come on.
The altar is in the raised room.
Come on, Roman.
I'm going to go in.
You started this, you're going to go.
Oh, shit.
Who, Bob or Roman?
Oh, God.
And since I had that cursed lookstone,
this will also be a disadvantage.
Wow.
I had a nat 20, guys.
I had a nat 20 and then a 7.
This is beautiful.
Don't give a shit, I'm running.
Oh, this is where I'm going to run.
I'm going to run out of dune.
What is going on?
I'm going to let out a hell of a mouth.
Oh, yeah, I'm definitely going to let out a hell of a mouth.
Listen, motherfuckers.
By the way, seeing room, first of all,
does that do anything?
Roman saw.
Nice.
Yeah, Bob's natural angle is hell.
Yeah, you're the bigger predator here.
You're the apex predator.
Let's go find this bitch.
Yeah, let's go.
Do they hear the how?
Can they hear the how?
That's what I'm saying.
Like, if they hear the how and then people come up,
like, hey, we just saw Roman do this.
Like, Roman, everything here, how?
That piece is getting ripped for a tire for the night.
He's just letting me see.
Yeah.
I don't go get them.
Let's be this 60.
Yeah, we still on that trail.
We hunt in this girl down.
An hour.
What do you think, Sue?
Or ten minutes, I thought it was an hour.
I'm not sure if I can do it.
Since we're away from people now,
would I be able to, if I do another,
what did you have me roll from?
But what I would I pick up her son again now that we're away from people?
12.
I got a figure out what Bob can say.
Do I still have the trail?
No moment that the magic drops, he's going to cost it again.
No, it's rich.
Oh wait, I have to, I have to have it.
Yes.
Let's go.
concentration.
Place mither.
No, there you go.
Yeah.
Yeah, we're dashing.
And where is the trail leading?
Like on the sea?
Yeah, also you're the tech master.
You can't pick me up something above you.
So he's good.
He has no vision right now.
He has no idea you're there.
And I have a question.
None of the townspeople would have seen her.
How to see?
Bob is going to stop.
He's going to look around and he will spot mouthless by now.
Bob, go back to the ship.
Which island is that way?
Bob, ship, no.
You're a pussy.
Listen, I was told if I found the lady, we would get rift.
Rift, I don't know what to say.
We would get rift.
The trail's leading out that way.
What is that way?
Yeah, what's on that way?
Tell me.
I can.
First thing he said, we consider it the same thing.
It needs to be done by the night.
And the night is almost over.
Not yet.
It's only been 30 minutes since he said it.
He's going to have mouthless.
If you say, okay, I'm going to say this.
If you say anything about an island or land or anything,
Bob is going to jump and swim.
I'm not going to give me right now because the character will jump and swim.
There is a day's world of ocean that way.
What?
There is a day's worth of ocean that way.
Days.
Oh, you know, well, Roma, wasn't the decision.
The decision is you'll have back to your ship and we're leaving desire and first thing in the morning.
So we still got to our morning, that's party.
I'm going to go get a high wills, painkillers.
Hell yeah, I got a lot of I got a lot of stuff over here and he pulled out the bomb.
Let's find those panders.
DM.
Oh, yeah.
I'm going to go and grapple one of the one panders.
No, no, I'm going to use an animal hand.
I'm going to use my animal hand.
And see if I can calm them down and see if they want to take a hit of your mind.
That's what I'm saying.
Okay, Bob gives you right now.
Yeah.
Oh, I just want to see if they take a hit.
Oh, my God.
Yes, yes, they do.
The whole night we're just passing the bomb.
Yeah, I'm going to go get a hit of your mind.
Oh, sure.
Yeah, I was still here because of the whole fun thing that was going on.
I couldn't leave.
Oh, God.
Oh, well.
Yeah.
For the other end.
I'm going to keep heading the way we were.
All right, guys, good luck.
Yeah, the next, uh, the next week, I'm going to be like in the dome.
Yeah, I'm going to be like in the dome.
I'm going to be like in the dome.
Yeah, but he wouldn't.
He didn't want it to.
He wanted to be asleep.
No, he just had like three.
No, he just had three cast of his shield.
He just had like his shield.
Yes, yes, I knew that.
I saw that like knockout strike and I saw, yes, I'm going to use all the shit right now.
They're going to be any more tries.
Yeah, I didn't understand.
Yeah, like he got too critical.
That's awesome.
And think that out with frenzy, he's going to have like two attacks.
I wonder why he didn't like take all of you.
Like he would have had three attacks like everyone.
I don't know.
Wait, do I have restoration?
Wait, I thought I had some kind of restoration?
No, no, no.
Greater restoration deals with the system.
Yeah, I can't do that.
I kept aid for like a low level mass.
Things to kind of like a hail Mary situation if person goes down.
Well, anyway guys, have fun.
See you.
Gonna go to sleep.
Good night.
[Music]
I mean, just say we're on a bit longer on the sea.
And then we'll fuck off.
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah.
I don't.
I'm actually like 12.
No, I don't.
I can do.
Yeah, two extra damage because of the physical.
Yeah, I mean, like monk gloves for like magic.
Yeah, boxing max is out of the 12.
I don't know.
What are you saying?
Yeah.
We have a gap.
I mean, um, Kate is our.
We don't.
That can't just any extra people we bring along.
We're going to be our.
Well, I think Zim is going to be our scholar.
Is it going along with us?
Yeah.
If we manage to.
When we saved them, she'll tell us where to go.
Now, if it's what classes.
What?
What class is your sister?
No class.
Let's make her.
Yeah.
That means we'll meet her mouth is.
Read.
See, I'm not leaving nor blue before we see it again.
I'm staying in the door.
And dropping is also in the North blue career.
Yeah, every Zim, dr over and Alice is out in the North blue.
Gotcha.
Yeah.
See, I thought they were all.
Separate areas, which are we needed drills, but if they were the same.
Yeah, but they are in the North blue.
So it's easier to navigate.
Yes, easy.
Yeah.
Well, that's what Zim knows that's the nose.
I'm going to tell us what happens.
Zim helped her escape.
But she's being transported to the North.
Yeah.
There's so many pieces to the puzzle.
Well, first get to the North and then figure it out.
Yeah, well, I was just not thinking about it.
I'm not going to be able to get to the North blue career.
One day someone else is going to pick up and we're going to like,
what the fuck happens?
Where's no guy?
If he starts swinging up after this, I'll know why.
I'm not going to make a show.
This one is me.
Good bye.